und vp regel nummer eins einer von unten
hat immerhin von uns immer besser ja wo
sind wir los jetzt hatte ich echt mal
lieblich nicht so geguckt da geht die
ganze körper fallen überall in den tisch
hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück zu
einer weiteren folge
minecraft landes mit mittlerweile beiden
dahinten tut mir auch der herr bergmann
rum und nicht das ärgert mich dass wir
da sein klare ja wir haben wir haben
gerade wir haben schon ein gespräch vor
dieser aufnahme und haben uns auch so
creeper briefe tschuldigung schuldig
floh ich beruhigt ich wollte vor den
audi heißt es immer leute aufnahmen hier
anmoderation verbrechen verfolgen können
du ich will gar nicht sagen hey das geht
ab reden wir haben oder wir haben und
brauchen ja nie ich wollte eigentlich
nur so ein paar schöne anekdoten bringen
also dass bergmann durch uns lieben dass
wir gemeinsam in urlaub fahren also was
aber über explodiert das ist ja
unglaublich diese nächte hier sind
einfach dass es so richtig es ist nach
wie vor stark war hier das tut mir leid
aber ja wieder aufbauen aber dass jemand
meistens verweigert wenn man das ist
fast so spannend wieder neue kurzfilme
auch nur fast
ach mensch ist jedes er ist heute
leichter airways auf krawall gebürstet
nein wieso es war das wort das auch
positiver soll ich finde ja gut
die stelle wo ich zu leise bin viel zu
leise aber findest du die nicht wissen
zu leise ich weiß nicht bisschen
vielleicht doch zu laut ist es fünfmal
hätten bisher immer noch nicht weil ich
bin ebenfalls das letzte mal als ich
gestorben bin in der letzten episode
das war übrigens die beste episode
bisher klare angelegenheit ja
nein all das muss auf jeden fall ein
bett haben weil er ist ganz
offensichtlich falschen fuß ausgestiegen
nichts gebracht
das hat heute den den bus außerdem auch
verpasst weil er dann eine kleine katze
auf die straße gelaufen ist machte ich
mich also was soll ich sagen das wird
man truck durch die gegend gefahren bin
und dann gestorben bist du auf dich hab'
ich habe ja gar nicht zu ende gesehen
oder eben kein urteil darüber bilden
manila zu ende gesehen ja nie leider
leider noch nicht irgendwie näher zu
bringen damit in der mitte ist mir dann
aufgefallen dass ein krieg bikes mobil
ist jetzt gerät alles jemals in ihrem
hause geht das ja macht das macht das
bild in der mitte ist mir dann
aufgefallen dass ich ja noch nicht folge
1163 von gongs minecraft geschehen ab
und musste ich unbedingt nachholen weil
da fehlt mir ja eindeutig was von egal
wie waren wie war dein tag heute auch du
mein tag war ich werde jetzt noch einen
skype an hat herr bergmann gewartet ich
war wirklich heute ich hatte ich habe
mir das jetzt mal seit drei tagen habe
ich mir angewöhnt dass ich mir
seit drei tagen habe ich mir wirklich an
gewöhnt dass ich mir vorliegen haben
kommen jetzt gegen das müssen wir
einfach mal jeden moment
du bist einfach mal die situation
ergreifen und das einfach einfacher
machen
es war der erste von drei strike bei 3
bist du draußen also ach so ja leute du
dann ist weil dann ist ja weil dem bald
für mich vorbei ja du etwas machst was
natürlich seitenpartie diese nacht so
auf was ich seit ein paar tagen mache
ist einfach mir immer am abend das
aufzuschreiben was sich am nächsten tag
machen möchte war das ein schwieriger
satz selbst das heißt ich habe mir
einfach gestern schon aufgeschrieben ja
okay ich mache dies ich mache das ja bla
bla
deswegen war mein tag heute mal
ausnahmsweise komplett sortiert das
heißt ich bin erst da hingefahren mich
da in japan nicht zur bank gefahren
damit noch ein stück eis geholt dann
weil ich zu hause und den ganzen tag
gelernt und aufgenommen weil ich freitag
mündliche abiturprüfung habe hu hu hu hu
hu hu und passen passen dauerzoff auf
diese tschuldigung ich wollte ich nur
kurz besuchen um 1 letzte schauen was
man was willst du eigentlich bauen
möchte auch sonnen sondern so ein
bisschen so passt dann über das wasser
ich habe ich ein bisschen verlaufen
mit meinen truck nicht mehr guck mal die
sonne geht auf
ich weiß noch gar wir wollen wir wollen
jetzt also nebenbei übrigens falls ihr
euch fragt was für insider bezüge die
ganz einfachen da geht es um den neuen
fulminanten kurzfilm von der bergmann
und das ist eine empfehlung wäre das
kann man mal kurz zu nebenbei hier
irgendwie abhanden kommen einer weile
wieder versuchen
insgesamt ist du nicht mal mehr dass ich
hier nette worte über die vertragen
nicht in eineinhalb mal wieder bergmann
im hintergrund ist dass der macht immer
forderung auch nett und dann dann kommt
aber die stelle von beiden seiten dass
keine stelle das ist einfach nur
gnadenlose bescheidenheit
okay okay okay nein das wollte ich weil
wasser das ist jetzt die erste folge
wieder mit dir zusammen und dann kann
man ja auch anmerken an warst du denn
eigentlich so
enthusiastisch strand fast in deinen
letzten tagen stunden wochen jahren
wichtiger ist es mir unglaublich leid
tut dass ich in den letzten in den
letzten beiden oder in der letzten phase
in einer folge den einer montagabend
eine folge dienstag kam auch keine folge
und am mittwoch was du nicht dabei dass
drei folgen haben nicht so wie die sonst
hätten kommen sollen
und das ist einzig allein meine schuld
weil ich das leider völlig falsch
kommuniziert hatte dementsprechend gebt
mir die schuld gibt nicht diesen beiden
süßen beust schuld wobei jetzt kommst
jetzt ein serbe ist das ein sehr
schlimmer finger und ein kleinganove
habs mir ich glaube ich hab's mir jetzt
echt irgendwie dem bergmann ich weiß
nicht nach gewerkschaft habe aber ich
glaube aber ganz schön verpackte nein
ist das ist auch der moment rückt ja
auch immer näher indem wir beiden das
ist wieso ich bin ich finde ich bin
irgendwie sontra paar jahre und ihr
beiden zeigt die ganze zeit aufeinander
los das ist unglaublich das ist ja dass
er so ein freundliches auf einer weiß
nicht dass er nachher wirklich noch
irgendjemand ernste und denke ich auch
gedacht das muss man natürlich immer
wieder zu erwähnen dass das beim
bergmann und mir so ein ganz ganz
freundlich aus schabernack ist den wir
halt gerne betreiben wie viele meter
ebene neue arbeit ist riskant böse enden
inception länger insider in inception
auf jeden fall irgendwas wollte ich es
gerade eben noch mal sagen stimmt
vielleicht haben einige zuschauer von
euch schon bemerkt dass die folge hier
ein bisschen anders abläuft als die
vorherigen denn es gibt kein thema das
wir bisher besprochen haben ist das denn
wirklich wir haben wir haben glaube ich
wir haben gerade ein daniela genau wir
haben einen das was wir machen wollen
aber was ich auch erwähnen wollte
wundert euch nicht wenn in den nächsten
beiden folgen vielleicht mal keins
vorkommt oder so was wir wollen auch
einfach mal das projekt und das gespräch
zwischen uns so ein bisschen vor sich
hin gehen lassen
das fanden wir irgendwie alle eine ganz
lustige idee deswegen vielleicht ruhiger
angehen bietet aber trotzdem themen hat
naja da können sie trotzdem immer noch
über den twitter hashtag senden
ich hab vergessen ja heißt handheld
leben direkt wieder mensch das ist
wirklich klasse hashtag bergmann
kurzfilm ich melde ich möchte irgendwie
sondern sondern sondern richtig schön
dick weg übers wasser bauen
aber ich weiß gerade echt nicht aus
welchem material ich hoffe ich mache
jetzt
ich einfach aus holz du bist ein
schlimmer finger du ja ich glaub ich
mach das jetzt wirklich geht aus der
geht also halb durch deinen das will ich
ja mal ich bin mit meiner bude ihn nicht
so wirklich zufrieden oder hab da auch
noch nicht so schnell den berg
der bergmann legt auf dem berg menschen
ja ich weiß noch gar nicht welchen preis
ich wollte ich wollte eigentlich so was
ähnliches wie wie herr bergmann bauen
ich war völlig weiß gar nicht was ich
baue ich laufe einfach hier nur quer
drumherum und für euch zu weil ich null
multitasking fähig bin komplett bergmann
wolltest du gerade eigentlich so preis
mancher sagen dass ich mich getraut
nee ich bin ich sicher was so der der
braucht einfach mal seien weder getriebe
von der seite management ja so wenn ihr
wollt oder muschel
ihr könnt mir gerne irgendwie ich weiß
wirklich nicht wo ich mich hin bauen
soll ich würde wirklich am liebsten so
ein baumhaus wäre cool aber irgendwie
auch nicht glaub ich freue mich wirklich
auf dem see so wie es vor als ob du hast
mich doch jeder wie freundchen nee mein
lieber mein lieber jung du hast mich
hier aus dem haus vertrieben weil du
meintest du baust du bist du ruhig so
klar dass mich bedient ok alles gleich
auf der karte gerner hinziehen nicht das
war nun mal jetzt für die ersten ich
möchte sogar einmal unter wasser sein
dass dein haus noch nicht gesprengt
wurde einst repro da bin ich wirklich
extrem froh dass dieses objekt der
schönheit der puren schönheit ja dass
das noch existiert habe ich mich für
eingesetzt der kunde da war in der folge
dass muslime reinziehen
sie hat mich gesehen aber ein monstrum
sondergleichen du also der war echt aber
auf 180 und wollte eigentlich eine ganze
bude auseinandernehmen ok hab ich ja
noch was du dann aber wieder
zusammengebaut
wer die pünktlichkeit nicht ehrt ist des
blockes nicht wert hat er gesagt
aber kann schwarzl man gebt mir mal
bitte einfach irgendwelche ideen die ich
hier wie ich bauen könnte ich mache
jetzt einfach mal sonst wie eben müssen
wir müssen jetzt rot pilz in projektoren
aber das wird oder was ist denn ich
hätte aber echt total bock dass aus
diesem rassismus muss ich hoffe jetzt
also mini zombie dem start automatik
bogen ist unglaublich kommentiert jetzt
alle so der reithalle hat eigentlich
eine verlustleistung ich klatschen jetzt
schon jetzt
man schätzt berg mal ein ich verteidige
kenia ist so ok das alt kommen ich weiß
ich bin einfach der beobachter ganz
ruhig ganz gratis ist kommentiert das
muss einmal schlagen beim fehler war
komplett nehmen und für vp regel nummer
eins einer von unten hast immer von
unten von uns immer besser
wir sind bei dir los jetzt habe ich mal
irgendwie problematik nicht so nicht so
gerockt
die ganze körper und fallen überall in
den tag
das vielleicht immer wieder wieder
bergmann ich habe leider mal in
vancouver volkslied alles im wasser über
dankeschön das habe ich weder serien
episoden gefahren jetzt hab ich mich
unter wasser hier durch die gegend
bewegen und ewigkeit aber ist aber jetzt
ist sie die die komische beziehung
endlich vorbei ich könnte auch gerne
helfen gemeinsam lösen
du hattest immer der böse kinos das ist
mit unserer böse okay das ist es ja toll
dass ich das weiß
du hast heute unter der sache muss jetzt
auch mal sagen ich beende weise projekte
nicht öffentlich aber dann bin ich raus
da kommen leute wissen alter land helfen
der ist ein monster wochen ein monster
rochen was machst du meiner bude daraus
dass da nichts mehr drin verloren wo ist
eigentlich mein priester hin
ein monster wochen
ich weiß gar nicht wie sie mit diesem
scheiß weg hier bauen soll das mit baur
eingestellt was soll das jetzt für ein
zeichen sein er muss jetzt muss jetzt
selber deuten können ist eine metapher
mein lieber aber das sieht richtig
schönheiten aus ich möchte am liebsten
ich glaub ich mal letzten boot gibt aber
ich hab hunger hat einer vielleicht aus
zu essen habe ich keinen karton habe ich
ja auch da wo du bist du da ich mache
mir gut ich wusste es du wirst du
durchschaubar ralph bergmann
das war ein bisschen wo ich bin ich bin
der marstall der der rest will ich
wollte ich wollte ins power point meinte
hier hinsetzen
kein problem der berg was möchtest du
denn wieder haben von allen sachen ja
nichts nichts
ich bin weg endlich etwas besser
razingar der flug ist ja ok wird man
teil eines majors gut kennen wir wollen
wir nicht vielleicht irgendwie bleibt
man jetzt hast du mich getötet ich habe
dich getötet wollen wir nicht eine art
wahrzeichen in die stadt setzen zur zur
wiedervereinigung
guck mal ich bin etwas überspannt alle
dass ich bin ich einfach versucht tiefen
falten normal zu kommunizieren
hey ruft ich fahre ich gespräche aus
fahrer gerade ohne spaß in so eine pinke
brühe und alles hier so wunderbar
farbenfroh wenn man die behielten
gegangen das sieht hier sowas von viel
schöner aus
jetzt macht unsere unser dorf wenig
schlecht
ich konnte nicht bremsen sobald du bist
nicht daran interessiert hier irgendwie
ein symbol der wiedervereinigung ohne
spaß leute macht euch mal bitte macht
euch mal boten kommt ihr mit hin
okay das ist ja unglaublich das ist also
schon möglich erst da muss ich erst
wieder vertrauen gewinnen also jetzt
auto as rom gebracht wie sie musste mir
zu vertrauen
er werde so viele andere fiese sachen
gesagt dass in dieser folge das muss ich
jetzt erst mal verarbeiten
aber was denn das müssen wir müssen das
werden die zuschauer wohl noch mehr
kommentare wie das hier könnte mal revue
passieren lassen mal gucken was dabei
rauskommt kommt
wenn man bei der forschung über deinen
werdegang betreibt gibt es aber auch ein
paar lücken im lebenslauf nicht das mal
das content jetzt leider ja
kommt doch mit du bist du denn wir
kommen ja gerade im hand in hand ach
guck mal und jetzt auch eine tonne
diesel
da möchte übrigens unbedingt auf diese
insel bei den extra und boden geworfen
ich weiß ich warum das ich benutzt
willst aber ist es kein gift drin dass
mir kein boot inn geworfen doch ich hab
den boden geworfen
nach quatsch nein mein boot fährt
unheimlich weg hey wo ich habe ein bild
gemacht profi nein mein boot fährt
alleine weg das wäre tatsächlich
ziemlich geile aus das gericht kommt
damit kommt man mit kommen einfach nur
luca luka kommt man hier mit hin
das ist ja das ist ja mal das ist ein
traum ein traum hier ich finde das so
schön hier also hier können sich
wirklich bestimmt einen baum
hallo bot ja ich habe auch das gefühl
also ich muss mir glaube ich echt
irgendwie eine neue hütte bauen dann aus
dem grund weil ich habe aus diesem aus
dieser alten kirche irgendwas gemacht
und das ist auch irgendwie so dass
anhand dieser merkmale dieser baum
regnet einfach direkt in einfach kleine
sternchen
ja ich bin schon wieder durch
irgendeinen scheiß pflanze gelaufen ist
das ist es er ist der traumhaft schön
hier
das ist es ist so schön dass ich dir
richtig hübsch dann los ist mittellos
musik wieder abholen schaut euch mal
angenommen weg guck mal hier könnte ich
irgendwie einer hinbauen also hier ist
ja mal richtig schön und dann würden wir
alle zusammenleben
deshalb kommt er her damit ich zeige
mich dabei wie ich mir das vorstelle
kommt mir hier hin nein denn reagierte
bleiben ja genau ich finds halt super
schöne kommen wenn sich irgendwie hier
einer hin bauen würde dann darauf die
andere seite dann da irgendwie dann
können wir da hinten was machen
dahinter habe dann das natürlich immer
noch das dorf direkt schon total aktiv
dabei fällt er vom baum natürlich ihr
könnt ich hin bauen wo ihr wollt aber
ich finde es wunderschön wenn wir
wirklich alle hier irgendwie hingehen
würden
finde ich super tolles neues bio
dann sieht dass hier schön aus ach ja
was passiert wenn man dieses holz hier
ach das ist ganz normales auto gut also
ich denke ich werde auf jeden fall hier
hingehen und wir müssen uns in der
nächsten folge auf jeden fall mal um
tiere kümmern und ich will auch sagen
das war schon wieder für diese folge
wenn es euch gefallen hat zeigt es uns
mit einem mag ich und soll ich sagen die
nächste folge gibt es morgen beim
bergmann noch mal sorry dass die letzten
paar tage nichts kam beziehungsweise
komisch was kam